Jason Takes Manhattan is the eighth
installment of the Friday the 13th
franchise and one of my absolute
favorites in the series a maniac trying
to kill us Welcome to New York did you
notice that our first ghost face in
screen six Jason was watching it on TV
before the real ghost face calls him up
unfortunately for him that's going to be
the last movie he'll ever see not a bad
choice though truly in the horror genre
a trip to New York City was not an
uncommon plot we got a list of movies
from Paramount that they owned that we
could use in the movie this is scream's
way of giving us a little nod to the
infamous Friday the 13th installment
that brought some of the most iconic
executions and the second we saw that
one we were like oh there it is it all
just fell into place